elle offre mag l'hijab c'est un état qui
a fait son apparition sur les réseaux
depuis deux semaines et qui était en
tête-- hier soir comprenez par ce
hashtag pas touche à mon hijab à cri du
coeur venant de la communauté musulmane
en france qui s'oppose à la loi
séparatisme voté par le sénat
nous voulons lutter contre le
totalitarisme islamique loi qui
interdirait le port du hijab aux filles
de moins de 18 ans dans les espaces
publics
senna ne peut accepter en france qu'une
mineure soit voilée si la burqa et le
niqab qui sont des voile intégral sont
interdits depuis 2010 en france le sénat
exprime aujourd'hui sa volonté de
vouloir renforcer le respect des
principes de la république
il faut combattre ce qui en est le
symbole mais le fait de priver les
filles de leur droit de choisir
constitue pour certains internautes une
atteinte aux droits des femmes
après l'interdiction du hijab aux
mineurs les accompagnatrices voilée et
le burqini la liberté égalité fraternité
est leo dans tout ça ce soit lille abou
zian étudiante en droit est avec nous
pour défendre le port du hijab le témoin
du jour est avec nous lie à bouziane
merci alors que vous avez commencé à
porter le voile alors que vous étiez
mineurs à tressin exactement est ce que
vous avez fait pas que si vous a fait
porter le voile à 13 ans alors je les
portais bahdja tout d'abord je tiens à
préciser que que je parle comme mon nom
je repeins aucune association je
représente personne c'est très bien de
le dire
et voilà j'ai pas de prétention de
représenter toutes les femmes musulmanes
en france qui porte le voile
donc c'est mon histoire à chaque femme
voilée à son histoire bah du coup
j'étais en algérie comme comme tous les
étés et un jour je les pages déportés
comme ça pour pour faire joli
honnêtement ce que j'avais bien à sortir
mes tenues avec le voile et c est en
fait au moment de sortir
majali l'enlever parce que c'était pas
dans le projet de le mettre à ce moment
là et je me suis senti bien je me sens y
est épanouie et
ma mère oui oui oui ma mère partie des
valeurs accor très bien mais à quoi vous
attendez vous à j'avais dit à 13h forêt
qu'ils portent tous un choix personnel
n'a jamais abordé ces sujets pour vous
dire qu'elle me voit avec en fait
justement ma mère elle est en france
c'est malsain azéri à quoi et quand je
suis rentré mais justement cela va à
pied j'avais dix commandements des
pizzas mais moi bien quand j'arrive et
quand j'arrive justement alma vendait
que les pizzas et à louvres elle me voit
avec avec les voiles et j'ai vu qu'elle
avait un peu un peu buggé m'a dit mettez
sur etc enfin qu'est ce qu'elle a lu
peur de quoi que que je devais que de
l'accusée me sur un coup de tête en fait
d'accord c'est ça soyez surtout parce
que c'est vrai qu'à 13 ans c'est une
décision importante
on se dit oui pourquoi à ce moment là et
depuis vous l'avez plus jamais enlevé
way exactement île rousse comme ça être
très heureuse et j'ai pas regretté une
seule seconde et j'ai pas bougé à 13 ans
je rougis pas aujourd'hui et je vous
dirai pas plus tard franchement je le
porte avec dignité
question posée oui oui oui papa qu'au
départ jusqu'à me rappelle des choses
pendant c'est vrai il n'est pas content
pourquoi parce que ils s'inquiétaient
c'était bienveillant fait s'inquiétait
de sur mon avenir en fait ils disaient
que salam fermé beaucoup de portes et ça
va être compliqué pour moi france de le
porter et que des jades pour lui avoir
un nom à consonance étrangère c'était
déjà un lourd fardeau n'avait pas en
plus on rajoute un voile puis aussi il
avait beaucoup peur que les gens pensent
que c'est lui qui m'a porté qui met sa
fin le porter quand vous marchez dans la
rue ils me disaient bah bravo tu as des
1 sur les conversations ceux qui
viennent de passer parce que c'est le
regard déjà en fait et comment ça se
passait au collège alors alors moi j'ai
fait j'ai fait une année de collège où
j'ai porté le voile dans un collège
public
d'accord ben je n'en locaux ask com
parce que comme vous étiez l'année
d'avant vous étiez dans ce collège quand
vous êtes arrivé à la rentrée mécanique
le voile est ce que il ya eu des
réactions de certains camarades il ya un
problème
franchement tout s'est très bien passé
après à l'époque on va dire que c'était
moins un sujet houleux j'ai l'impression
maintenant c'est vraiment voilà
maintenant c'est un sujet tabou mais
alléchante et que là en ce moment le
regard des gens a changé par rapport à
quelques années oui ah oui totalement
vous avez vraiment je suis totalement
bas à l'époque au collège et j'ai même
pas ressenti une quelconque gêne ou un
quelconque rejet de mes camarades j'ai
été très apprécié tout le monde de mes
professeurs également j'étais enfin
j'avais de bons résultats il y avait
certains professeurs qui m'avait vu
devant le collège avec d'autres non
on croyait le projet loi qui a dit qu'il
fallait plus porter le voilà dans un
établissement
oui donc en fait vous enleviez le voile
juste avant de rentrer dans le halal de
marque collège ou dans le lycée et
ensuite vous leur métier en partant
c'est certainement ça vous a dérangé ou
bien c'est vous comprenez cette décision
j'ai un contrat je l'entends je la
comprends ce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
lisent voile à l'école est laïque donc
forcément voilà on veut pas de signes
distinctifs religieux
vous comprenez ça honnêtement à cette
époque là je ne me suis pas vraiment
posé la question de la loi c'est la loi
à venir faire une révolution
déjà c'est vrai j'ai mes pieds et voilà
voilà
le témoignage là et les médias la wii
forme est là parce que voilà ça ça
vraiment il y avoue fait du bien ce soir
in salah à plein de gens en plus qui
sont pour ce projet de loi qui arrive
voilà le projet de loi sur le
séparatisme adopté au sénat voudrait
interdire le port du voile dans l'espace
public pour les mineurs vous vous avez
porté le voile à la partir de l'âge de
13 ans maintenant vous n'êtes plus
mineures forcément mais vous comprenez
que même à 12 13 14 ans on puisse avoir
des convictions qu'on puisse avoir un
choix peut-être religieux un choix de
vie et aujourd'hui il ya peut-être des
jeunes filles pourront plus avoir ce
libre choix comme vous l'avez eue vous à
l'époque oui exactement mais moi je
trouve ça vraiment scandaleux en fait
c'est une atteinte à la liberté j'ai
l'impression que ça à chaque pas grand
monde
alors que enfin c'est une atteinte à la
laïcité parce que tout le monde croit
que les musulmans sont contre le
principe de laïcité alors que moi en
tant qu'étude entend droits en tant que
citoyenne française en tant que
musulmane
j'y suis fortement attachés et c'est au
nom justement de la laïcité que que ce
projet de loi il me baï meurtre je vais
vous dire ce qui dérange que vous allez
me dire ce que vous en pensez mais moi
ce que je ressens ces cas beaucoup de
gens et j'ai lu ce qui se passait sur
les réseaux sociaux j'ai eu un petit peu
les réactions par rapport à ce projet
doit il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
une mineure est forcément poussé par ses
parents mais ça n'est pas son choix
personnel c'est pour ça que c'est la
première question que j'ai déposée avec
votre maman et votre papa votre papa en
plus c'était contre vous me les lisiers
votre maman a été même pas au courant
donc vous vous êtes vraiment l'exemple
le contre-exemple parfait et envie de
dire et alors vous gilles verdez vous
comprenez que voilà que ce projet doit
puisse déranger bien sûr moi il me
dérange parce que pourquoi choisir à la
place des gens ces jeunes femmes comme
madame où ces jeunes adolescentes elles
ont envie de porter le voile et foire a
été de croire qu'aujourd'hui on oblige
des jeunes adolescentes à porter le
voile
ils ont envie par choix par conviction
et on va encore une fois les discriminer
encore une fois on va séparer les gens
pour leur religion pour leurs croyances
donc je trouve que ce projet de loi du
sénat il est violent méchant
jean-edouard badella ce qu'il faut
préciser c'est que depuis quand elle
rentre à la maison sa mère a arrêté de
lui acheter des pizzas
moi je suis contre le contre ça parce
que je considère que ces gens là sont
les amish de la religion musulmane
c'est à dire ils sont ultra conservateur
si on trouvait sur une si on les écoute
bien thomas revenir à la calèche
mais je crois que parce que quelques
mois que c'est l'image que vous en
faites pas du tout où palais qui en fait
les gens qui parlent des gens qui pousse
justement les enfants à mettre le voile
j'ai croisé une fois le à rosny sous
bois une gamine de 4 ans qu'avait le
voile juste ya un moment me dites pas
que la gamine de quatre ans elle a mis
sa part contagion mais au secours c'est
une vaste blague c'est ça c'est un mode
de vie aussi il faut un mode de vie le
voile est comme une casquette à ce
moment là mais non mais vous allez venir
voit par ailleurs voilà vos parents
peut-être qu'il y avait il avait
certaines coutumes et qu on est sous
l'influencé des parents rosières qui
renaît sous l'influencé raison à 12 13
14 ans on peut faire un choix seul c'est
ce qu'a fait mais je tiens à préciser
que tu fais arrêter la gamine de 4 ans
qui portait le voile on se doute bien
qu'elle va pas la maternelle avec un
voile elle devait c'était peut-être un
contexte elle se rendait sûrement à la
mosquée donc elle s'est habillée comme à
la mosquée doit s'habiller etc
mais franchement ça cdd déjà une
minorité non mérité en fait mais c'est
même pas le mot parce que vraiment c'est
des cas vraiment isolé pas de moi je
fais partie d'une famille musulmane dans
mon entourage j'ai beaucoup de musulmans
et les non-musulmans m'aider moi j'ai
des musulmans entre autres et j'ai
jamais vu une gamine porter un voile
j'ai mes bases investisseurs extérieurs
les ai jamais vus avec un voile sur moi
donc commencé voilà toujours des gens
qui nous sort des mes exemples qu'on n'a
jamais vus en voilà c'est vrai que s'il
ya un exemple parmis parmi nom est cité
des noms et sans moi ce que j'aime moi
voilà dans le témoignage de lui là c'est
que c'était sa propre conviction à
l'achat des part entière elle l'a dit
elle l'a dit il n'ya en fait l année
parce qu'elle trouvait belle avec au
départ c'est ça c'est dur mais après je
mais c'était
il y avait plus sa spiritualité ça
démarre à goma c'est à dire que ce
n'était pas bon la saison c'était pour
les raisons d'une jeune fille de 13 ans
voilà que s'est dit tiens je vais je me
trouve bien comme ça je vais le mettre
oui effectivement j'entends tout à fait
votre discours et il est tout à fait
audible et il est vraiment bravo à vous
affirmer d'assumer mais en revanche la
loi moi je crois qu'elle est là aussi et
ce projet de loi il me semble qu'il est
là pour protéger les plus faibles
mais il y à des jeunes femmes comme vous
bien évidemment mais il y en a d'autres
qui sont plus faibles et vous je pense
que la loi allait peut-être la perdre et
non pas pour vous oui mais pour elle
mais s est fait pour c'est un vieux
singe en armement cette bagarre c'est
pour ça que je pense que c'est pas mal
de dire à 18 ans 18 ans on est une jeune
femme adulte majeur dans la république
et donc à sa 18 ans ont fait évidemment
ce qu'on veut et si on veut porter le
voile à ce moment là mais on le porte en
revanche mais il ya un autre chose parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'amendements dans
cette loi et c'est pour ça que j'aime
pas le côté fourre-tout ne touche pas à
mon hidjab parce que évidemment ça ça
pose ça pose question pour le coup cette
cet amendement là qui est celui qui
empêche les mamans voilées
adam et les enfants avec dom d'amener
les enfants dans les sorties scolaires
ça par exemple pour moi il n'ya il n'y a
pas de sujet un v6 3 normalement se
rappelle aussi de
l' affaire julien odoul lorsqu'il y
avait une jeune femme voilée qui étaient
arrivés moins ridicule au conseil
d'administration qu'il avait eu un
comportement exécrable ça c'est un autre
sujet exactement là quand on est on est
sur le sujet des mineurs et du voile et
vous aviez un contre argument oui en
fait ravaler rixe est en fait votre
argument il feint une femme peut
rappeler justement un argument qui m'a
toujours dit tu as toujours agacé sur
les plateaux télé mais c'est pas l'autre
c'est celui de ya des femmes en iran qui
se battent pour l'enlever alors enlevé
le ski et moi j'ai envie de dire à ses
parents français oui bien sûr mais en
matière à ces personnes là d'aller en
iran et de redire et des femmes qui se
battent en france pour le porter par
exemple twitter c'est pas parce que il
ya des personnes qui ceux qui ont un
certain combat qu'on doit interdire à
tout le monde en fait de le porter
certes la loi elle est là pour protéger
et tant mieux que silva existe parce que
ce phénomène existe
puisqu'on en parle mais c'est pas une
solution que d'interdire à tous le 1000
m oui sauf que la france un pays laïc et
l'iran un pays qui est régie par la
charia est en attente des laïcs
maintenant l'aspect des six mois de la
religion de tout le monde allait bien
sûr se prêter au jeu
alors quand à l'arrivée son attention et
son établissement c'est toi pour la wii
par rapport aux mineurs c'est que il me
semble qu'elle est bonne la communion d
une communion conséquente on est mineur
des barbies le fait d'exposer ont fait
des gestes en tant qu'enfant donc
attention là on monte quoi une fois de
plus excusez moi il a dérobé excusez moi
une fois de plus c'est pour ça que tout
n'est pas blanc et tout n'est pas noir
une fois de plus c'est pourquoi encore
désigné on n'aurait pas ces noix pour
expliquer qu'on met pas une croix ou
incrusté céline se désole on n'aurait
pas fait non plus pour les besoins kippa
et là on le fait pour le voile et sa
main ces déchets pour l'annoncer pas en
tout cas c'est pas
oui mais sa sacoche c'est ce que je vous
dis mais sur l'accord mais c'est comme
ça que je suis désolé il ya eu il ya
quand même une distinction je suis
désolé franchement c'est ce que je
ressens et c'est pour ça qu'à des
problèmes parce que effectivement on
agite toujours le foulard avec l'idée de
le dire 2 on agite 16 et moi ça me
dérange et dieu se rit parfois je suis
extrêmement dur pour moi là la frontière
celle de l'école laïque oblige il n'y a
pas de problème là-dessus effectivement
quand on est dans un syndicat on va pas
avec un pour moi on ne va pas avec un
mode mais dans la vie de tous les jours
quand on se balade et qu'on a même
sceller les enfants en balade en quoi ça
dérange qu'une mère
j'attends la régression jean-edouard
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que le voile
est ce que c'est choquant de voir un
enfant mineur porté un voile aujourd'hui
moi je pense pas les gens qui
soutiennent cette loi disent que ça
symbolise l'inferno l'infériorisation de
la femme sur l'homme
moi je pense pas historiquement quand on
s'intéresse aux origines du hidjab ce
sont les femmes libres qui portent le
hidjab
c'est même un signe de distinction
sociale donc moi je pense que ce n'est
pas grave est pas choquant de voir
quelqu'un porter le hidjab et surtout il
faut laisser les gens faire ce qu'ils
veulent et arrêté avant qu'il s'endorme
j'écoute j'entends tellement d'eau
chaude et loisel vous avez raison de
porter le hijab si vous en avez envie
vous êtes totalement libre ici c'est un
pays libre
voilà vous avez le droit et il faut le
faire en revanche le vrai problème où je
vous le rappelle mais en revanche parce
que votre histoire elle démarre comme
les marseillais à dubai et genre j'étais
en vacances en algérie
je sais ça tellement mignon je les
portais que ces mêmes références m6
aussi dans l'exposition que vous avez
utilisé le ministre une autre histoire
je la respecte mais ça démarre un peu
comme ça ont trouvé ça mignon avec vos
cousines algérie très bien mais ça ne
s'est pas un problème
ceux là où je veux en venir c'est que
vous voulez être avocate je crois vous
voulez plaidé en hijab
j'aimerais bien c'est ça mais ça c'est
pas possible oui d'après la loi
française est non et ben non
la loi française d'origine c'est à vous
le savez ériger cette voie là rappeler à
vous vous allez plaidé vous allez dire
voilà c ou c o quand vous allez être
avocate est certainement une grande
avocate
je pense que benjamin castaldi aura
besoin de vous contraindre edf à l'image
est plus européenne vous inquiétez pas
il ya des problèmes
[Rires]
vous allez nous a dit que vous avez joué
vous allez respecter directes gelées
depuis j'allais venir
en fait en tant que qu'avocat enfin tant
qu'avocate du coup puisqu'on parle du
voile
on a le droit de porter le voile parce
que c'est une profession libérale on a
le droit d'assister des personnes en
garde à vue adoptée et à des auditions
la seule réserve donc c'est pour le fait
de plaider
voilà et en fait c'est bah c'est là où
je m'interroge parce qu'en fait ce n'est
pas par ce n'est pas sous couvert de
laïcité c'est pas le principe de laïcité
qui réalisait cette voie là c'est plus
les coutumes de la profession la
symbolique de la robe et c est en fait
avec un groupe d'avocats justement quand
parce que je pense que vous avez lu mon
article sur la croix voilà et bas à
partir de là donc il ya eu un petit
groupe d'avocats qui s'est formée donc à
majorité bas c'est ma part majorité s'il
n'y a quasiment que des non musulmans
qui ont réfléchi parce qu'il suffit
d'avoir un cerveau pour réfléchir et qui
se sont dit ceci serait ce que par don
c'est pas ça ici se sont dit qu'en fait
c'était pas le principe de laïcité qui
régissaient la profession d'avocat et
que du coup le fondement sur lequel on
se bat pour cette interdiction est ce
qu'il est vraiment est ce que c'est
vraiment fonder justement c'est là on
s'interroge et du coup on a un petit
groupe de réflexion une petite tribune
etc et on si je bossais sur bélon voile
quoi qu'est ce que ça vous j'aimerais
vraiment nous plaidé sans effacer cette
défaite envoie et c'est ça ma question
mais non mais le corps qui se paie
d'ailleurs le plat la loi la loi le port
de la robe est réglementée et
uniformiser pour hommes et femmes
pour tous la zakât sans signe distinguer
exactement d'origine religieuse c'est la
règle philosopher de politique où il
tirait imaginer un avocat qui est
naturiste
voilà il va plaider à poil au cap daksi
juste de la portée de toute manière donc
c'est pour ça c'est la team pro b c
selon les convictions et mes critiques
observée pour les avocats leader tout le
monde doit porter le rire
dans un souci de neutralité ça qui est
important c'est ce qu'on vienne ils
n'arrêtent pas de m'appeler c'était pour
ça je crois qu'il voulait un chauffeur
routier c'est que vous fait vraiment
plaisir parce que vous êtes rayonnante
et vos parents sont top parce qu'ils ont
été compréhensifs et vous ont laissé
maintenant je pense que dans certaines
familles effectivement comme l'a dit
valérie peut-être qu'on est contraint et
forcé par la tradition et le poids de la
tradition et de la dignité et tout ça
donc lorsque la loi régit c'est
peut-être bien et à 18 ans on est libre
de choisir juste une question si vous
allez à la piscine ça se passe comment
j'y vais pas du coup voilà donc deux
majeurs et majeur parce qu'on a des
convictions ok on se prive d'aller à la
piscine je suis désolé avant 18 ans et
puis même après les jeunes à 14 ans 16
ans on a envie d'aller à la piscine
pourquoi est ce que cette spiritualité
au delà du foulard matériel ça nous
contraint aussi dans la vie donc les
jeunes ne peuvent pas aller à la piscine
par exemple même du tout qui vous qui
vous pose un peu problème mais là j'ai
envie de dire qu'il ya eu un petit peu
d'épis solution pour aller à la plage
avait le burqini oui mais ça sent le
sens le matériel aussi qu'on peut être
semé rituel à l'intérieur mais là rien
de dire c'est que
c'est que moi c'est spirituel aussi et
puis j'ai pas de signe distinctif la
pratique de marge maintenant mais
pourquoi tu te prives demandé sa
spiritualité sympathique mais il ya
plein de musulmans dans son spirituelle
sans le laisser passer le congé pas des
contraintes et des amis qui portent ce
voile de ce qu'ils ne portent pas
j'ai aucun des musulmans qui sont
spirituels même en allant à la personne
ment mais bien être a dit le contraire
mais balancer mais excusez moi à la
piscine qui s'est passé m merci jouer
conversion milliards d'avoirs
m